the effort to stop another parkland or
Columbine or Sandy Hook from happening
is the top job for Congress right now
chief congressional correspondent Mike
Emanuel tells us if anything substantial
is happening on gun control and school
safety students from Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School took to Capitol Hill
today their message less talk more
action a message not lost on Speaker
Paul Ryan who seemed conflicted over
president Trump's push on arming
teachers to make American schools safer
as a parent myself and as a citizen I
think it's a good idea but it's Speaker
of the House I think we need to respect
federalism and respect local local
jurisdictions House Democrats backer
proposal targeting firearms like the one
used in parkland fifty people supporting
it right now so I think that's pretty
clear in terms of the overwhelming
majority but that idea is a non-starter
for Republicans the proposal that has
the most bipartisan support tightening
up background checks by incentivizing
States and federal agencies to send
information to the National instant
criminal background check system it's
backed by Texas Republican John Cornyn
and Connecticut Democrat Chris Murphy
I'm encouraged that the president seems
to be willing to do something a
background checks something significant
he's endorsed online comprehensive
background checks Senate Democratic
leader Chuck Schumer wants a full debate
on gun issues and says just background
checks won't cut it if that is all
Congress does we won't have done our job
to keep America's family safe but Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell notes
the gun issue brings out passions on
both sides we've been down this path
before there are bipartisan differences
about how to address this issue
McConnell says the focus of Republican
senators at lunch today was on school
safety and not guns Democrats are
clearly worried Republicans will pass
the bipartisan background checks measure
and say they are done ret my command you
live on the hill Mike thanks